palpable
hoy estamos en el aeropuerto
internacional de kotoka en accra ghana y
es realmente un momento histórico
estamos muy felices de recibir el primer
lote de vacunas contra el kobe 19 a
través de cobb accessibility 600.000
dosis de la vacuna desarrollada por la
universidad de oxford y astrazéneca
aterrizaron en ghana provenientes de
india donde fueron fabricadas
representan la inmunización de 300.000
trabajadores de la salud y personas de
alto riesgo en este país africano que
empezará su campaña de vacunación el 2
de marzo son vacunas aseguradas por el
mecanismo de cooperación internacional
kóvacs una iniciativa liderada por la o
ms de la cual dependen la mayoría de los
países pobres para combatir a cabalidad
el kobe 19
hoy culminan muchos meses de planeación
investigación negociación y coordinación
pero es sólo el principio todavía
tenemos mucho trabajo para hacer
realidad nuestra visión de una
vacunación equitativa
y es que el proceso de compra y
administración de las vacunas es de todo
menos equitativo mientras la unión
europea y eeuu han asegurado la
adquisición de cerca de 3 mil 800
millones de dosis regiones como áfrica o
américa latina' no suman ni siquiera una
tercera parte de esta cifra
precisamente kóvacs quiere equilibrar la
balanza y proveer a los países de
ingresos bajos y medios suficientes
vacunas como para inmunizar al 20 por
ciento de su población para hacerlo
necesita al menos dos mil millones de
dosis de los fármacos desarrollados por
el momento ha adquirido más de la mitad
una carrera contrareloj para asegurar
una inmunización justa